[Music]
is council culture ruining art
after writing a forthright blog about
her views on gender identity
the artist jester wars has been accused
of being a transphobe
for years recently her critics hunted
her down and she was cancelled
and then uncancelled she joins spectator
tv now to tell her story
jess you've been through quite an ordeal
can you start by explaining what
happened
well um i
have been well cancelled and uncanceled
really
by the royal academy lately which was
just
the culmination really of what has been
more or less a two-year witch hunt um
of myself since i wrote a blog post
a lengthy blog post sort of outlining my
thoughts on
gender identity ideology how i feel that
impacts feminism how it um impacts well
language
how it impacts free freedom of
expression and all such things and as an
artist how it impacts me and as a woman
of course
and uh and ever since i published that
in 2019 um
i had a bit of a anti-fan club who's
been
using anything at their disposal to try
and
hijack any work collaboration that i've
been doing any
any anything at all really like um they
would have preferred if i would just
basically disappear from the face of the
earth i guess
and so this ended in this
extraordinary situation where somebody
found out that
uh the royal academy stocked some of my
merchandise some of my embroidery
patches
um which they have done for more than a
year but they found it out
now because i have a sneaky suspicion
that someone basically
joined my patreon because that was the
only place where i shared this
and literally a day later is when this
online campaign mounted against me once
again
tagging all the places that stock my
patches
um saying how can you associate with
this transphobic person
you should be ashamed of yourself yada
yada and then and one of the biggest
accounts was the royal academy
and then on cue within a day i got an
email from them
saying that they had eight complaints um
against me
from the general public well it wasn't
it was
a group of embroiderers no less online
who
um had basically encouraged their
followers to
to go and complain eight people and they
need to investigate this because they
stand with the lgbtq community
i told them so do i this is a concerted
effort to try
and shut me up has been for a long time
and i don't think that it's a good idea
to drag this into the public
because i could bring many more than
eight people
to explain to them what my position is
and that it isn't
based in hatred that it isn't
anti-trance or any
any of the of the things that these
people say and then i didn't hear back
for another world two days but the day
in between i found out that they
had via social media essentially dumped
me saying thanking those who brought to
their attention
my misdeeds my misgivings and they will
no longer stop this transphobic artist
um yeah and then and and it was horrific
so
so you first found out through social
media they didn't tell you
they did not they only then got very um
[Music]
worried i suppose because i also then
went to social media because it just
felt like
what else is my recourse i had done in
the meantime i went to the police
because the
the this kind of bullying campaign that
has been going on for so long
it felt for the better part like there's
nothing much i can do because a lot of
the perpetrators are based in the states
or based on canada and stuff and so
there's not much
what do you do you know um and
but this time it was a woman who is an
embroiderer who was based in london and
i thought okay well there has to be
something it has to be some sort of
recourse went to the police
turns out there really isn't much of a
recourse
um yeah and it was super frustrating and
then i went to social media
reposted the screenshot of the royal
academy saying this is where we're at
then i left social media because it was
just super depressing
again that something so big had happened
and um
yeah and then i woke up to an inbox full
of journalists asking to interview me
because
it suddenly had gone completely huge
and was it only after the media
attention that the royal academy
apologized to you because they did
apologize in the end but was it only
after the pressure from the public
oh yeah i mean they went completely into
lockdown mode for i think five or six
days i mean
unheard of apparently i spoke to so many
journalists in the meantime
um their press office just shut down
completely any
like you know the times that the the the
first interview
and uh janice turner tried to contact
the press office
no like just they just didn't respond
anymore they went completely silent for
five days
do you think it's um i mean you know
it's incredible because there's the head
of the royal academy who apologize to
you so do you think that
the whole thing was just ill thought
through and there was some junior social
media manager maybe got saw the pressure
on social media and just
took the decision or do you think it was
actually a consistent thing that
the organization has thought about i
don't think they thought about this in
fact i don't think
most organizations have thought this
through i think a lot of people think
this is just
the sort of you know because the the
continuous mantra as you know don't be
on the wrong side of history
just be kind all this sort of stuff it's
represented as though
people with my view which is i would
posit probably the majority of every
like of of the general public which in
and of itself doesn't mean i'm right
and i'm always happy to be challenged
but i would say that
the way that people try and and uh
present my view as a controversial one
is very deliberate and so i think
a lot of people haven't thought this
through at all because i was in the same
situation two years ago when i still had
a little salon
on the site and soho theater and and the
same thing happened after
i published the blog they um got mounted
with
media social media pressure by you know
keyboard warriors
and they also had never thought about
this so i don't think
i genuinely think that there there's a
huge problem in most organizations at
this point because
a lot of this ideology has flooded in
from the universities
it's unsupervised because you know like
the older generation kind of things oh
they know better about social media and
all this
and they just go and do their thing you
know and so no i think it was
extremely rush and then speaking to them
on the phone because i did speak to them
even though they didn't speak to the
press anymore like
because they got really flustered and
went like oh it's gone mainstream and
like oh no
no joke yeah well it has
of course it has let's talk about those
views that you mentioned
um can you tell us what you wrote in
your blog from 2019
well so i mean it's a very long blog
it's like a 5000 word blog because i've
spent a long time thinking about this
but to encapsulate it's basically
um stating what my views are on
words the meaning of words how i
understand what a woman is that it's an
adult union female that
that it's not an identity it's not
something i believe anyone can identify
as i think you can identify with but
that's a different thing because
you are the sex that you're born in
that's what i've been writing about
and this whole idea that we should
encourage people to just
go along with this mantra trans women
are women trans men are men
it's just not true that's just not true
and um
i've had so many conversations now also
with with um
journalists where they try to put it
as though this is an opinion that's not
an opinion that's a scientific fact i
didn't make that up
and so far i mean sure science also
changes once we know
new things but as far as i'm aware this
is what the state of affairs is i've
been looking long and wide because it
would have made my life much easier if i
would have found scientific proof for
those assertions which there just
isn't and i had a million conversations
so that's what i put into that block
that it really worries me this um
thought policing really worries me
the degrading of language worries me
the the towing the party line as an
artist if i can't explore certain things
that are important to me
why bother making art i don't do it just
for that the decorative um
you know purposes i do it to be able to
sort of work through things that concern
me
and all this kind of stuff so if i can't
do that anymore because immediately i
will be called a bigot or
transphobe or i want all people dead
that just doesn't work so i put all of
that into the
the blog i said i find it increasingly
concerning that
uh the trans-red activism that i've been
witnessing is incredibly sexist it's
very homophobic and it's
really it's really quite violent when
you look at there's like a there's like
a website where this has been
um collected it's called turf as a slur
dot com and i hadn't even known when i
started looking into all this was what
turf
means which is trans exclusionary
radical feminist and
again there's so many labels like i'm
just jess those are my
views and i felt like i need to make a
position because i come from such a sort
of like liberal arts background and
people suddenly felt all betrayed
by me going hang on a minute this is
i don't this doesn't make sense and
unless you can make it sense for me
this doesn't work for me and i will call
it out so to clarify then do you think
that it is possible for someone to be
trans or you think it's not even
possible for trans
are you saying that essentially that
they are deluded that in believing that
they could be a different gender
well so i don't believe in gender right
so i i
understand that to be transsexuals which
is someone who wishes to present as
though they are the other sex and
most of the times those that i've spoken
to uh um
who share my views they call themselves
transsexuals not transgender because
again
gender is this idea and this is where my
feminist
background comes in gender is this idea
that there's certain behaviors that
women do and that men do and so
therefore to me that's really sexist
like if anything i'm a gender
abolitionist i don't you know just
because i'm a woman i shouldn't have to
do certain things just because someone
is a man that shouldn't have to do
certain things where certain things you
know
that's the problem with it so the idea
that you identify as the other gender
what does that even mean other than a
sexist stereotype and i have yet to come
across
a coherent explanation of what that
means without using sexist stereotypes
so i don't think they're deluded sorry i
don't think they're deluded i just think
that um to demand that i see them
because i see this often really
conflated that i see them as though
uh someone who's born a man now says
he's a woman that i should then look at
that person and go okay are you a woman
i can see how someone would want to
express themselves differently
fine to me but now seeing that this
whole thing has become
so ideological i even struggle with this
whole
you need to call me this you need to
call me that it
no i don't need to do that
and i think what's often missed from
this discussions with you as you
mentioned so many journalists have
talked to you
it's actually that you grow up in a
household which is not
gender conforming you write about your
father in your blog
from 2019 and you can see pictures of
him here and
he's clearly not what we typically think
men a man should dress like but
he doesn't identify as transgender
himself he does not no
but according to stonewall he would be
uh transgender because
stonewall's definition of transgender
lumps in anybody from crossdresser to
the whole you know and and no he doesn't
he just
he he's literally um you know like eddie
isn't used to say those are not close
uh those are not women clothes they're
my clothes um and
and that i find so refreshing because
that is exactly what i would solute
anyone
in doing you know like not adhering to
those sexist stereotypes
you know just wear whatever you want and
do like dress
you know whatever makes you happy but
that isn't what that is
that isn't what we're talking about you
know and so yeah my dad
likes to wear heels and put on makeup
and
nails i don't have nails
my dad yeah he loves doing it he loves
doing it but he he thinks of himself as
a paradise bird
i think he likes to challenge the gender
stereotypes by doing this in particular
also like he likes to walk around like
that in general because he likes the
look of it
but i think there's part of him that
likes to challenge war
you know like i think he quite enjoys
when people look and go what
and the point is that as a man he can do
that without being a woman and as a
woman
you know you might not want to have
nails and big breasts and you can still
be a woman and that's the point isn't it
exactly that's the point yeah and just
you know since this entire ordeal your
um
orders have gone through the roof um you
do embroidery but
there's some of them are off what you
call big swinging ovaries which
in this day and age people might think
it's transphobic
um so do you where can viewers get get
their hands on some
oh they're still i mean they have to
have a lot of patience for now you've
got a big waiting list
i've got a big waiting list i've got
i've had to employ people to help me
with this and even with that we have
such a backlog because the demand has
just shot through the roof
i've got someone sitting in my studio
right now fulfilling orders
and then of course there's the
commission because i do commission work
this is what i used to do
like the the merchandise is on the side
um that i could
um subsidize my
um my my art um career so now
it's just gone i've got a waiting list
for commissions i've got
i've sold all my big artworks all my
small stuff so
yeah it's gone yeah on my website and if
anyone wants to know about new artwork
they're gonna have to subscribe to my uh
mailing list or my patreon you know
well i mean clearly people are voting
with them voting with their wallets and
they really have yeah
[Music]
you